welcome to cloud minute let's take a  look at how to upload files and folders  to Google Cloud storage  first go to the storage browser and  select your bucket you can click upload  files to select files and folders from  your file picker but my favorite is the  drag and drop features here you can just  drag and drop files and folders straight  into the web UI now let's open a command  line in the folder with the files we  want to upload I want to upload file to  and folder to to cloud storage to upload  file to first type in GS u 2 then C P  then the name of the file and finally  the name of our cloud storage bucket if  we refresh our Google developer console  we can see that the new file has been  uploaded now let's copy folder to type  in GS u 2 then - M for multi-core then  CP then - R for recursive then the name  of the folder and then the name of the  bucket if we refresh our Google  developer console we can see the new  folder with all the files inside of it